welcome everyone to this simple learn
demo on maven here now in this one we
are going to talk about that how we can
work on maven installation on Windows
and one too flat from here so first of
all we'll do it on the Windows platform
here and we'll see that how the install
generally works so for this one I will
be doing the installation to my local
system now before we've been going for
mavin mavin is in kind of a build tool
which is available their primary for
performing any kind of build automation
for the jar based projects now since
it's so used for Java we also require
the jeddak installation onto our system
so for that both of the installations we
will be covering over here and we'll see
that how the installation really works
as such over here right so before even
going for maven we have to install the
JDK onto a Windows machine so that we
can proceed with maven because maven
requires the JDK installation should be
there now there are two ways of JEDEC
installation either you go for the exe
file or you extract the boundaries of
Cherokee to or directory and then setup
the job on disk or home path for that
but if we are using in the executable
that will perform the path
configurations for you also so in that
case you don't have to reconfigure it
again and again so that's what we are
going to see here so first of all we
will try to do the installation of GA
decade so for that we'll go to the
website of JDK and then we have to click
on this one to access the maven
installations part here so that's what
we are going to do so let's proceed and
let's open the chrome and try to go
through these two URLs so that we can do
the installations one by one so here I
have to choose search for JDK 8 download
so it will show me the URL for Oracle
comm so here you will get the JDK for
the different platforms for different
operating systems now here what you can
see here that you have the
configurations in which you have the
Cherokee installation so we have to so
here I'll go for the windows 64 version
because that is something I will be
using to do the installation so this is
the complete executable link so here you
can download so we are down leading the
as
kay a the you 251 so just search for
Windows 64 yeah this is the one so let
me click on this one
let me quickly so once the login is done
you will be able to see that it's trying
to download the exe file so that was for
the JDK for the Java now for the Maven I
am going to go for the maven download
over here so in this one the maven repo
link is there
maven dot Apache dot o-r-g is the link
for this one now here we have the
different options you can see here that
the binary Civic archive is there then
so slave archive is there so depending
on the installation which you want to
perform you should be able to download
that file and it works there
so let's first install the jdk potion
and then we'll call with this one
so we'll click on this one also anyways
because it's something we have to
anyways to it so we'll click on this so
that this maven is also getting started
install downloading over here so once
both of them are downloaded we will
proceed further with this setup so let's
wait for another 1 minute to do this one
so the Apache maven is kind of
downloaded over here so we wait for the
JDK download also over here so next 5-10
seconds only left odd
so first JDK will be there and then
maven installation configurations will
be there so for maven we just have to
extract into a directory and give the
mvn home path into the properties into
the variables so that it can pick it up
over there
okay so we have to extract the zip file
for maven give the path and then we will
say we'll check with the maven command
whether it's working fine or not so
let's try to install the executable so
we'll open the directory where the
executables are there so first of all
we'll install the JDK so we'll double
click the Installer for JDK itself
around 200 MB so the complete JDK will
be installed so we have to just go for
next now when you go with the Installer
so usually the Java home paths and all
that stuff is already configured so you
don't really have to change the
passwords or Java home or any kind of
variable you have to put it up all those
things will be automatically cleaned up
it's running the installation
close so then we have to extract the
Maven so we have to extract this
directory because here they may even
complete educate abel's and libraries
are there so we just have to extract it
and place into a directory so that we
can further on use it and X is the path
so once the access is done yep so this
is done Thea so I can rename it to like
even so I can rename it like to ask me
one and I can cut it down and put it
into the C Drive here now this is the
maven home path which is going to be
there right so all I have to do is that
I have to close this one and this one
and this one and this so what we have to
do is that we have to really go to the
system properties so that we can extract
it so I'm going to open the system
properties over here properties now here
the advanced system settings now in this
one we will be setting up the paths the
environment variable will go now here if
you scroll down you will see all the
different paths which is available there
as such over here
now if we want to see that if the Java
is fine or we require for JDK also so
all we have to do is that we have to
open the CMD prompt window are we are
providing so using the window are I'm
opening the run window where I can say
like CMD now in this CMD I am going to
say like Java
- version Java is there so which means
that we don't have any problem as such
now
just go here and setup a new one called
env n underscore home so here the same
path so you can browse for directory
also but I am using the ambient home
over here in this one now I have just
added that and in the path variable in
the last we have to actually add the bin
directory also so that whenever we run
the MV in command so that should also be
resolved so and we an underscore home is
not the only variable which you will be
configuring in fact you will be
conferring the path variable also that
you can go ahead and put up a new
directory entry for the CMD here so CMD
till the CMD directory you will go there
and whatever the executable is there you
should be able to resolve that so for
that again you have to open the window
our CMD prompt Java - version and then
you can run in vien - version here when
you run the MV in - version it will let
you know that which particular Java
Runtime you are using one point eight
point zero underscore 251 that's the
same one which we have configured and it
also let us know that where exactly the
suitable is there and we can now proceed
further with the execution of the maven
build so you just have to check out your
source code or go to the directory where
source code is there and you can run the
MV and clean install so that will
ultimately go for the build process so
this is the way that how we can do the
installation of maven on the Windows
platform now since this is done now we
will go ahead with the second
installation where we are going to do
the installation of maven and JDK onto
the open to machine so for that we will
log into the particular cloud lab of
simply learn ill LMS so let's login to
the LMS here so now we are going to do
the installation of JDK and maven on the
Ubuntu virtual machine here so for that
we will login to the LMS so let's login
to that so this is the elements over
here here I have already started the lab
here so all I have to do is that I have
to just click on this link here so it
will open the lab into a new tab
it's a GUI more of Ubuntu server so
which we will be using to configure it
so here first of all I can open the
Chrome browser also so let me open the
browser here so that I can download the
Maven executables as such so JDK we can
do it using the package installation so
using the apt as you get able we will be
doing the installation so I have to just
open the terminal here so once the
terminal is opened you have to login
through the route ID now why we require
route ID so that we should be able to do
the package installations and other
configurations so that requires root
access
now once that is done you have to run
the particular app update Kumada next
you have to install the Installer so the
Oracle installer we have to install now
once the setup is done so let's down
install the latest package over here for
a curl Oracle - Java 14 - installation
so this will install the JDK 14 over
here so for that configurations now at
the same time we'll go for maven
download also so here we'll go for
download maven so this is the tar file
for executable so I'm going to copy this
URL here
and over here we'll say yes yes yes so
now the java should be configured and
could should be set up over here in this
one so what we really need to do is that
we need to run the Java command to see
that if the installation is done
properly or not so let's open the
terminal again another terminal so that
I can perform the steps related to maven
so I have got the URL so I'm going to
the opt directory which is always a
optional directory where we can do the
setup and all those configurations so
I'm going to run the W git command and
then the URL which I have downloaded so
this should download the tar file over
here of maven now once that is done so I
have to extract it so da - xvz F and the
tar file name this is a tar gun zip file
so I have to use da - xvz def parameter
over here to extract it now what exactly
I have got I have got the Apache maven
directly over here so I am going to
rename it in order to rename it what we
need to do we need to actually go for
the particular move command so move
whatever the existing folder you have
and then I am going to rename it with
the maven directory now once that is
done I am going to the maven directory
and this is the path or maven underscore
home path which is available as such
over here in this one so here all the
bin directory is as you give us all this
stuff is there so now I can use it like
m
let's go home and the same configuration
just like we did in the window so here
also it the same process we have to
follow so Java - version should be let
me know that which version is deployed
so 14.0 one version is deployed over
here so for java i do not don't have to
setup the path again here because i am
using for the Installer so I don't have
to setup the path right
so for maven now what exactly I have to
do I have to go to the EDC profile D now
here I am going to put up a particular
file now here you can see that we have
the JDK a file here which means that the
path variables and everything is
configured as such over here so you can
see that Java and is go home but all
these variables are copied here so I'm
going to also create a same file similar
to this one here but in this case what I
am going to use it that I am going to
remove some of the values so I'm going
to have some of the parameters added so
in order to do it effectively I can do
the echo command so that I can copy the
things from here and I can simply pull
up into the file here so I'm going to
have the path variable added up over
here now why I am putting up the paths
because it's the same configuration
which we did over there also so opt /
May 1 / pin so all the bin directory
should be added to the specific path
variable so I'm just trying to create a
file called maven dot SS just like a JDK
dotter as such over here I am also
creating similar kind of file over here
called maven dot Sh now I'm not going in
the VI mode or other editors because I
just want to make you understand that
how I am copying it the content I'm
taking the JDK dot s such as in
reference and putting up the details
over here in this one and then I am
going to export MV an underscore home
over here which is related to like opt
slash maven so this is what we are going
to put up over here and then maybe in
the end maven this is the file which you
should be having now why we are using it
because of the fact that it's being used
or it will be utilized in such a way
that you can perform the changes or
whatever configurations you want
this will help you to set up the certain
parts like a path and ambien home so
that you can run these scripts as such
over here so I'm going to give the
executable permissions to this one and
that's it
so now what exactly I have to do is that
I have to do the source here profile dot
d M even once that is done I will be
able to run the ambien - version over
here and the JDK path is already open so
it's going to refer to that part so this
is the way that how we configure the
meeven and the JDK specifically on the
Ubuntu virtual machine so pretty much
that's it for this demo in this demo
b-prime we talked about at how we can do
the installation of Cherokee and maven
on Windows and how we can do the similar
tasks on the maven on the Ubuntu virtual
machine also here so that's it for this
mo thanks hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simple learning
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here